if as i suspect it is a law court they
should never practice law again they
should be disbarred for this because
this is handling sensitive information
information that was not theirs to
release and you know as a law clerk they
drill this into you it was made clear to
me when i was a law clerk at the supreme
court for justice alito
you you don't take draft opinions
out of the building ever you don't take
it to lunch you don't take it home it
shouldn't even leave your office when
you're finished with it you can't just
throw it in the wastebasket you've got
to put it in this special bag
so you mentioned politics entering the
court
obviously at this point because politics
has become our national religion it
seems almost impossible not to i had
judge napolitano from fox on a couple
weeks ago in the middle of the katanji
brown jackson hearing and his position
was that basically
the senate should confirm a judge that
is you know nominated by the president
barring something really off the charts
like really really beyond unbelievable
in a decision that they made that
basically the decision should be left to
the president and short of something
really catastrophic the person should be
confirmed now we watch confirmation
hearings and on both sides it's it's all
sorts of you know dredging out all kinds
of horrible things or made up things in
the case of brett kavanaugh um perhaps
in katanji brown's case the fact that
she couldn't tell you what a woman was
maybe that was a catastrophic thing that
would have qualified but what's your
general position on when a president
nominates someone what the process
should actually look like look i i make
no mystery about the fact that um
when there is a democratic president in
office i understand that we're not going
to get the same nominees
as we would
when there's a republican
holding the office of the presidency
still
it still matters and it still matters to
me to review each candidate individually
and figure out whether he or she
uh understands respects appreciates and
will defiantly protect the independence
of the judiciary and will
understand
that
each case is to be decided on the basis
of its own merits and on the basis of
what the law says
on the basis of the law as it was
understood at the time of an it's an
accident if a statute or at the time of
its ratification if it's a provision of
the constitution and so i'll vote yes
for a nominee even if that nominee
doesn't share my political world view if
i think that nominee
uh is sufficiently committed to the
judicial task if not i won't so i i
don't know that that ought to ever mean
um blind deference to any president
whether that president is of your own
political party or not uh it certainly
doesn't mean that to me and i don't
think it should to anyone else either
you mentioned the dobbs case before you
know it's kind of bizarre you know this
this leak happens you know now it's
probably six weeks ago or so
and
basically not only are we not talking
about it anymore but it doesn't seem
like anyone's trying to track down the
leaker um are you aware of anything
that's going on that maybe we're not
fully aware of through the media yet and
and what do you think that the leak
itself
uh has done to the integrity of the
court
you know until fairly recently i i was
convinced that they had identified the
leaker and they just had made a
strategic decision within the court not
to announce the leaker's identity until
after the dobbs case was decided which
may not happen until the end of the
court's term which usually wraps up in
the final days of the month of june
but then a few days ago
news reports started to surface
suggesting that the investigation is
still ongoing that they've asked law
clerks there are four for each justice
to submit their phone records and submit
sworn affidavits
about their
conduct of this in this case about
what if anything they have done with
copies of supreme court opinions so it
seems to be that the investigation is
ongoing i do think they'll figure it out
who it is because we're dealing with a
fairly finite group of people
and it's uh it's not that hard to figure
out i think we'll find out whoever it is
if if as i suspect it is a law court
they should never practice law again
they should be disbarred for this
because this is handling sensitive
information information that was not
theirs to release and you know as a law
clerk they drill this into you
it was made clear to me when i was a law
clerk at the supreme court for justice
alito
you you don't take draft opinions
out of the building ever you don't take
it to lunch you don't take it home it
shouldn't even leave your office when
you're finished with it you can't just
throw it in the wastebasket you've got
to put it in this special bag a bag
whose contents are retrieved at the end
of every day
they retrieve the contents they
shred the documents not just once but
twice turning it into a confetti
and then they put it in an incinerator
and put it into this black powder and
then they add a little bit of water to
it and it creates this tar-like slurry
structure before it ever leaves the
custody of the supreme court of the
united states that's how seriously they
take the confidentiality of the opinion
drafting process so whoever did this
knows darn well what those procedures
are and why they matter that's why that
person should never be permitted to
practice law again i do think they'll
figure it out
so assuming they do figure it out or
even if they don't what do you think
it's done just generally to the to the
integrity of the court the ability for
the court
to make a decision hold a decision until
the time is right for it to be released
and just the way the media reacts to all
of it because obviously this was leaked
to politico
they had their decision on whether to
release it or not or
verify it in other ways from everything
we understand it is legit but just the
general standing of the court which to
me the left is constantly trying to
subvert anyway not just through packing
but generally just assault all of the
decisions
yeah i think it's devastating
i think it's devastating the court has
enjoyed a a a history in which this has
not occurred now but the
left-wing media is fond of saying things
like oh this isn't the first time this
has happened other leaks have happened
yeah sure every once in a while maybe
once or twice in a decade word will leak
out maybe an hour or two before an
opinion is released
suggesting that the person knows what
the answer is going to be and most of
the time it's a 50 50 guess anyway it's
like betting on red or black at the
roulette wheel you're going to be right
on average half the time and sometimes
they get that right
but they've never leaked an entire draft
opinion this has never happened before
there's been a a
network of trust within the court and
there's been
unanimous support within the court and
its support staff and making sure this
doesn't happen
so i think we can stem the damage moving
forward as long as the court takes
additional security steps to make sure
this never happens again but i think
they're gonna have to put in place some
sophisticated watermarks uh behind every
draft opinion from now on that will
identify uh the the person who had
access to that watermark so that a leak
like this can't happen and if it does
happen the person will be immediately
found
so you mentioned federalism earlier in
states rights obviously
as i mentioned to you right before we
started i spent the last eight years of
my life in california i now live in the
free state of florida and as i've been
saying on the show i i genuinely feel
like i live in a different country not
in a different state but in a different
country i'm wondering what what do you
see differently on the ground in terms
of what your constituents want in utah
and the way that you feel that you can
govern there
versus what goes on when you show up in
dc and what you have to deal with yeah
that's a good question look
most americans i it's true of utahns and
i i'm pretty sure it's true of
californians and people in massachusetts
in wyoming or whatever state you want to
identify most americans intuitively
resonate with the concept of federalism
and by the way i refer to it by that
title rather than as states rights
because i my belief is that a state is a
unit of government
units of government don't have
rights they have authority authority is
almost the opposite of a right so it's
recognizing the appropriate sphere of
government authority that's what
federalism is and most people understand
that federalism makes sense because it
allows for more americans to gain access
to more of the kind of government they
want and less of the kind of government
they don't want if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell